but first a foray into the world of
books and the leipzig book fair we think
literature is alive and well even if
some critics claim otherwise sasha stana
Shh won this year's leipzig book fair
prize he came to Germany at 14 as a
Bosnian refugee his book fought mfest or
before the festival explores a
little-known area of his new homeland
he's been banned mr. garage I'm
completely surprised and extremely happy
I was given an egg on my way here often
i think the egg is from the oka Marcus I
I hope it's from there ja phalluses fun
dot is from the same small village in
eastern Germany where fordham Fest is
set here there's plenty of unspoiled
nature stories and myths stunna [ __ ]
rights of a talking fox and a drowning
ferryman mixing the imaginary and the
real cow has in become divers came Tosh
remote made them coffee they drank it
and looked out at the lake and then went
out into the lake and hauled in the
ferryman big men blonde and taciturn
verbs in the imperative load the
ferryman then famine the idea for the
book came to him during a trip to the
former Yugoslavia the landscape and the
places he saw came together creating a
fictitious village in his mind the mind
Hawaii my fondest but my girlfriend said
she knew a place very much like what I
described her and she took me to first
invaders small community in the
northwestern oak amok and there I came
across it ahi the Sun
not long before Stan eh1 the book fair
price writer Maxim biller sparked a
debate by calling contemporary German
literature boring emotionless and
self-centered he said immigrants had
little chance to break into the market
and then only if they assimilated his
comments outraged many in the publishing
business you're joking what's it about
contemporary German literature is
anything but boring it's richer than the
talk would have you believe basically
what's happening is what we expected van
calm did fight again about 200
second-generation immigrants mittens and
feel they also have something to
contribute to literature here but enrich
this with experiences and images from
other parts of the world your uncle
maritza Bo Dragic is of Croatian descent
when she was 10 her family fled the
former Yugoslavia for Germany her roots
and her memories play a major role in
her books kir charts and I'll take a
fooler or a cherrywood table is about
war invading people's everyday lives it
deals with death loss and starting over
in another country
how reliable are ones memories how does
one become the person one is today these
are the questions but Dragic asks in her
book my new maxim allocating bodies the
German language is my present but i also
have a past i come from somewhere else
and i bring the two together but it's
not as if you go slavia outweighs
everything else I've also written tales
of utopian islands which deal with
personal dreams which are my own I'm
also a poet and go where my writing
leads me or my death boy in describe me
food and there are lots more interesting
things happening on the German literary
scene right now skip degaussing
gesellschaft Romana t he is in the
script to you there are examples of big
social novels which are here there are
others that look back at history and
novels that deal with the division of
Germany so there's plenty of subject
matter without even venturing beyond our
own borders vignan subash writing is at
CNM enough for your star April is a
novel set in the time when Germany was
divided it's about a girl coming of age
in the East German city of leipzig in
the 1970s her mother is an alcoholic so
April grew up in a home for children but
April doesn't let that get her down she
gets to the west and she makes her way
in the West Berlin of the 1980s but a
constant search for love is her undoing
this fictional biography of an East
German woman has many parallels to the
author's own life I think April needs
this East German identity even if she
later goes to the west for 25 years she
was socialized in the east and that
gives her a certain strength Katya
Petrov scaia was herself socialized even
further east in Ukraine but she's lived
in Berlin for 15 years now in her debut
novel maybe Esther she traces her own
family history a Jewish grandmother from
Warsaw was murdered by the Nazis
in Kiev
maybe Esther is a chronicle of a family
dispersed but even more it's a
reflection on political turmoil in
Europe Robert needy families every
family provides an opportunity to
understand the greater things in the
world nothing more it's an introduction
to world history to the understanding of
many things political undog matic and
humorous these authors are different and
so are their books boring they are not
you